what do you think marx would say if he
just looked at the
different implementations of the ideas
of marxism throughout the 20th century
where his ideas that were implicit were
made explicit
um
would
uh would he shake his head would he
enjoy some of the parts of the
implementations like how do you think he
would analyze it well he had a great
sense of humor i don't know if he had a
chance to take a look at his writing but
he had an extraordinary sense of humor
my guess is he would deploy his humor in
answering this question too
he would say some of them are inspiring
some of the interpretations of his work
and he's very pleased with those others
are horrifying and he wishes somehow he
could erase the connection between those
things and the lineage they claim
from him which he would
uh as a german word i don't know if he's
lying if you speak the other languages
there's a wonderful german word called
fatsita
and it's stronger than the word refuse
it's if if you want to refuse something
but with real strong emphasis
is a german way of saying i i don't want
anything to do with that
and he would talk then you know in
philosophical terms because remember he
was a student of philosophy he wrote his
doctoral thesis on ancient greek
philosophy and all the rest
he would wax philosophical and say
you know that the ideas you put out are
a little bit like having a child you
have a lot of influence but the child is
his own or her own person and will find
his or her own way and these ideas once
they're out there
go their own way and as you said there's
a particular way that this idea spread
the speed at which it spread throughout
the world made it even less
able to be sort of stabilized right and
connected back to the origins of where
the idea came from
the only people who ever really tried
that
were the russians after the revolution
because they occupied a position for a
while not very long
but they occupied a position for a while
in which
i mean it was exalted right there had
been all these people criticizing
capitalism for a long time even the
marxists ever since mid-century
and these were the first guys
who pulled it off
they made it and so that there was a
kind of presumption around the world
their interpretation must be kind of the
right one because look
they they did it and so for a while
they could enunciate their
interpretation
and it came to be widely
grasped as something which by the way
gets called in the literature
official marxism the very idea that you
would put that adjective in front of
marxism or soviet marxism or russian
there were these words that
where the adjective was meant to somehow
say
kind of this is the canon you can depart
from it but this is the canon before the
russian revolution there was no such
thing
and
by the 1906
it was already desperate it was gone but
for a short time you know 30 40 years
it was a kind of
and the irony is
particularly here in the united states
where the taboo against marxism kicks in
right after world war ii
is so total in this country
that
i for example through most of my adult
life
have had to spend a ridiculous amount of
my time
simply explaining to american audiences
that the marxism they take as canonical
is that old soviet marxism which wasn't
the canon before 1917
and hasn't been since at least the 1960s
but they don't know
it's not that they're stupid and it's
not that they're ignorant it's that well
the ignorance maybe but i mean it's not
a mental problem it it's
the taboo shut it down and so all of the
reopening
that in a way recaptures what went
before
and develops it in new direction they
just don't know nevertheless that's the
serious attempt at making the implicit
ideas explicit the
the russians
the the soviets at the beginning of the
20th century made a serious attempt at
saying okay beyond the critique of
capitalism how do we actually build a
system like this and so in that sense
not at a high level but at a detailed
level it's interesting to look at those
particular
schools maybe right because for example
let me just take your point one step
further you really cannot understand the
cuban revolution the chinese revolution
uh vietnamese and the others because
each of them
is a kind of
response let's call it to the way the
soviets did it
are you gonna do it that way well yes
and no is the answer this we will do
that way but that we're not going to do
and the differences are huge
but you could find a thread i can do
that for you if you want in which all of
them are in a way
reacting
to the originals yes
very much so like maybe most of rock
music is reacting to the beatles and the
stones there's something like that
you